[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Today I want
to talk to you about machine
learning for game development.
But before we dive
straight into that,
I want to take a step
back and show you
some of the magical use cases
we've seen in consumer apps.
So for those of
you that use Gmail,
you may be aware that
the spam filter in Gmail
is actually built
on an ML model.
And this model
evolves over time,
because users can tag
something as spam or not spam.
And the model actually adapts
over time based on that.
One of my favorite use cases
is actually Google Photos.
So if you wanted to fire
up Google Photos right now
and go into the Search field,
and type in the word car,
it's going to give you
back all the images
in your personal library
that have cars in them.
That's not because you
went and labeled them.
It's not because someone at
Google went and labeled them.
It's because there's an ML
model behind it that's actually
able to recognize objects,
landmarks, locations,
and even your pets.
So it turns out that
games and game development
is actually a rich area for
machine learning research.
And in 2014, DeepMind
joined us and started
using games as a way to do
their machine learning research.
So in 2015 they talked about
how they use some classic video
games for ML research.
So what we see on the left
hand side there is "Breakout."
And what they did is they used
a form of machine learning
called reinforcement
learning, where the model
itself only had
access to the inputs
that it could provide the game,
the visuals, so the screen,
and the score.
And the goal was to try and get
as high a score as possible.
So it didn't know
how to play the game.
It was just working
out its own way.
And within a few
hours, it was one
of the best "Breakout"
players in the world.
Actually, if you look at
the strategy it employs,
it creates a gap on
the left hand side,
and lets the ball
go through the gap,
and let it bounce
off the top wall
and clear the bricks itself.
A year later, DeepMind
surprised everybody
by building an ML
model that was actually
able to play the game of
Go and defeat some world
champions, the world
champions at the time.
And more recently in
the last few months,
DeepMind and Blizzard have
been talking about the work
that they've been doing
together with "StarCraft II,"
and building an AI that can play
"StarCraft II" competitively.
I recommend you go
and check it out.
Actually, again, they
pitted the AI Alpha
Star against some
pro esports players
and were able to defeat them.
So what we're
seeing is games are
a great place for ML research.
And we want to be able
to find a way that we
can use games in our
own applications,
in our own game development.
But not everybody has a team
of machine learning experts
like DeepMind does.
And as you can see from the
numbers here, less than 2%
of all developers have any
machine learning expertise.
And fewer still are deep
learning researchers.
But at Google Cloud,
what we want to do
is democratize machine learning.
We want to find a way to make
ML available to everybody
so that you can
innovate and find
use cases where it's useful.
So today, I'm going to be
talking to you about how
you can use machine learning
for specific areas of game
development.
We're going to start
with player experience,
move into data analytics, and
talk about game development.
But the important
aspect here is,
we're kind of going to go
from easy mode to hard mode.
So think of these as
difficulty in your games.
So let's get started
with player experience.
We've been doing ML
research for years.
And what we have done
with that research
is exposed it as a set of APIs
that you can readily use today.
Now, these are pre-built models
based on our vast data sets.
And we've just exposed
them as REST API endpoints
where you can consume them
either on your server,
or directly through
your clients as well.
But these are generic APIs.
And I'll cover a few of them.
Let's look at some
specific examples
where game developers
could benefit from them.
So we're living in a world
where, increasingly, we
have a global gaming audience.
We have players that are able
to connect with each other
from vastly different
parts of the world.
And language is,
frankly, a challenge.
Some game developers have
used techniques like emotes
to try and get
around this, where
we limit the type of
vocabulary that can be used,
and that makes it
easy to translate.
But when you're in
the thick of battle,
in a battle royale game, and
one of your squad members
speaks a different language
to the other folks,
it's really hard to coordinate.
So we can do better here.
Now, you may have heard
of Google Translate.
It's a consumer
application where
we can translate languages
from a source language
to a destination language.
You may have seen it
in Google Chrome, where
if you go to a website that's
in a language that's not
your default language,
Google Chrome offers
to translate that for you.
But we've exposed
that as an API.
And we call it the
Google Translate API.
I'm going to switch to a demo
just to show you how it works.
So can we switch to the
demo machine, please?
There we are.
So here is actually just the
landing page for the API.
cloud.google.com/translate.
And when we scroll down,
you'll see that we've actually
got a demo that you can see.
So first thing I'm going to
do is click the recapture.
And switch languages.
So the type of thing that we
might have players say is, oh,
good game.
Have fun.
And we can do it across
different languages.
So let's say we choose Dutch.
You'll see it's responsiveness
is incredibly fast.
We can say something.
Just good luck.
Oops.
And, again, we can
switch to any language.
What you'll see,
though, when I expand
this is that request URL
is all that's needed.
We have a couple of parameters,
query parameters, where we say,
here's what the source text
is, what the source language
is, the destination language.
And then we provide our API
key for billing purposes.
That's it.
And what we get back is a
nice little bit of JSON that
gives us the translated text.
So if you have any sort of
chat messaging in your games,
this is a way that you could
translate between languages.
All right.
Let's switch back to
the slides, please.
So even though we're enabling
people to talk to each other,
people aren't always
friendly to each other.
You may have noticed
that on the internet.
And what this does
is it actually
creates a bad experience
for your other players.
When you've got one person
dominating the conversation,
or a group of people that
are being hurtful to others,
it really causes problems.
And the way developers
treat this sort of scenario
these days is that they
provide a mechanism for players
to report other players,
report bad behavior.
At which stage,
you gather a bunch
of diagnostic information,
maybe some chat logs,
maybe they're
in-game recordings,
and so on, and you pass
it off to a team that
has to triage it.
That's a manual effort.
Triaging that sort of
work takes a lot of time.
We have an API called the
Cloud Natural Language
API, which can actually
detect sentiment
in individuals' chat messages.
So as a way of quickly
triaging through reports,
you can quickly
identify where you
may have some problem
areas in your logs,
and make that triage
process a lot simpler.
Increasingly what
we're seeing in games
these days is that
developers are
starting to adopt
things like AR,
where they're using the camera.
And they need to
be able to detect
what type of objects
that are in the scene,
or what type of locations
they're in, maybe landmarks.
Another example that we see
is lots of game developers
are providing ways
for your players
to create user
generated content.
It might be items.
It might be custom images.
It might be even maps.
Turns out that if you give
people the ability to upload
whatever they like,
they can, again,
upload things that are probably
not appropriate for everyone
there.
Now, we have an API
called the Vision API.
And it is able to do things
like object detection,
and also able to flag
explicit content.
Now, Vision API is really cool.
Because it's giving you
the kind of power that we
have in Google Photos, that
example I used earlier,
but giving it to you as an
API that you can readily call.
Now, before I
switch to the demo,
I just want to get some answers.
Can anybody tell
me what that is?
I'm hearing Eiffel Tower.
Any other thoughts?
All right.
So we'll switch to
the demo machine.
We're going to look at
that image right now.
This is our Vision API landing
page, cloud.google.com/vision.
And what we're going to do
is drop an image on there,
hit the recapture again.
This is, again, just a demo.
But what we're doing is
uploading this image.
And if you said Eiffel
Tower, you were wrong.
This is actually the Paris
Hotel and Casino in Las Vegas.
Now, when that API
returned us a response,
it actually told us
what part of the image
that it used to recognize
what this landmark was.
And so you can see
there's a green highlight,
or a green bounding
box around that image.
And the way that it knew that
it wasn't the Eiffel Tower,
The Eiffel Tower doesn't
have a building below it,
unlike the Paris
Hotel and Casino.
Now, because this is a
real place in the world,
we're able to get some
useful information.
We're able to see that this is
a real landmark, where it is.
We're able to get links to
the web that says what kind
of information this is.
And we get object detection.
We get labels.
We can see that
this is a landmark,
that this is a
tourist attraction,
and actually, that we even have
a lot of the sky in this image.
And then we get Safe Search.
So we can see what
kind of image it was.
I was going to give you an
example of an explicit image,
but legal said no.
So we'll have to move on.
All right.
Let's move back to
the slides, please.
So that's the Vision API.
And when we look at
some of these use cases,
you can see that just
by using our APIs,
you're able to solve kind of
low hanging fruit, quality
of life type problems.
It can really improve
your player experience.
But for you, you're getting
the benefit of an ML model
without having any ML
expertise yourself,
because we've done that work
for you, and we've exposed it.
Now, even though we only
looked at three of these APIs,
we looked at Translation,
Natural Language, and Vision,
we have a number of others.
We have Cloud Speech, which
will do speech to text and text
to speech.
And we also have
Video Intelligence,
where we can look at videos
and tell you where objects
are in different scenes.
So we can identify cars at
the start, buses, planes,
all sorts of objects.
And we can transcribe
videos as well.
So you get actual
captions for your videos
with specific timestamps.
So when you've got any sort
of recording in your game,
where your players are able to
record their last few minutes
of gameplay and so
on, Video Intelligence
can be a good way to kind
of index that if you choose.
But you may look at
that and say, hold on.
These are very fixed use cases.
I have more needs than just the
ones that the ML APIs provides.
And we have some solutions
for you there as well.
I'm going to look
at an example game.
We're just going to make it up.
Let's pretend we have
a flight simulator.
And it's a very realistic
flight simulator.
Look at my graphics.
It almost looks
like it's a photo.
Right?
It is a photo.
But this simulator
is so realistic.
We've used procedural
weather generation.
And what we need to do is, as
the weather conditions change,
we need to be able to know how
we fly, what type of planes
can we use?
How should the player
do his or her thing?
Well, it turns out that in
order to predict weather,
looking at clouds is an
important way to do it.
And it turns out that
we have a few categories
of clouds, just a bit over 10.
And when we look at those
clouds, the type of cloud
is a great indicator
of weather patterns.
But the problem is, if we use
the Vision API that I just
showed you right now,
the Vision API gives us
some useful information.
Hey, you've got
some clouds there.
Hey, there's a sky.
But it doesn't go to
that level of detail
that says what type
of cloud it is,
because these are general
purpose machine learning
models.
Now, traditionally
you would have said,
oh, your APIs don't work for me.
I'm going to have to go and
custom train an entire ML
model myself.
Now, for those of you that
don't have ML expertise,
that is a huge learning curve.
It's not an
insurmountable problem.
But you have to
suddenly learn ML.
And data science is actually
a profession on its own.
So it's not something that
you can easily pick up.
Wouldn't it be great
if we could get
the benefits of having
some ready to use model,
but with our custom data set?
Well, for that we have
something called Cloud AutoML.
This is huge, because it means
that you can get custom built
models for your
use cases, but you
don't need any ML expertise.
And we do all of this through
a simple graphical user
interface.
So when we look at
AutoML Vision, the way
that it works is that
you provide a labeled set
of images, your photo data set.
You pass and upload it
through our user interface
to AutoML Vision.
It trains up a model.
And then it deploys it and
serves it to you as an API
that you can readily consume.
Now, that's huge.
Because one, there's a lot of
work to just train a model.
But it's also a lot of work to
scale out and deploy a model,
such that you can depend on it.
We're going to look at
that in a little bit.
So the way machine
learning, in general, works
is something along these lines.
Now, this is not meant
to be intimidating.
This is actually a screenshot
from the TensorFlow Playground.
TensorFlow is an
open source framework
that Google built
for machine learning.
It's the most popular ML
framework in the world.
On the TensorFlow
website, this playground
is a way for you to visually
try and get some experience
with building ML models.
And what you'll
see straight away
is across the top there's
a number of parameters.
We call these hyper parameters.
Things like the learning
rate and activation function.
And then we have these
columns of squares.
Each column is called a layer.
And in those
layers, we're trying
to extract certain features to
be able to identify something
for our use case.
The goal here is actually
in this output field.
So on this output image,
these dots actually
represent the test data.
So when we train an ML model,
we have a huge data set.
The bigger the data
set, the better.
So you split it
into what's called
training so that the training
data set is used for your ML
model to learn.
And then you have
a test data set,
which is what you use to
validate that that model is
working as appropriate.
And in this example,
we have our data.
And each of these dots
that you see in the output
actually represents
the test data.
That's the right answer.
So you see blue dots
and orange dots.
And what you want to see is that
the background behind the dots
matches the color of the dot.
So that's where our ML
model is predicting.
And so what we've done here
is we have a number of layers.
And you'll see this spiral
shape data pattern that we have.
That's pretty good.
It does its job.
But it's complicated.
And the process of
machine learning
is such that what you do is you
start with a set of parameters.
You train it.
You test it.
You look at whether
you're happy with it.
And then you tweak
it, and you go back.
Train it.
Test it.
Tweak it.
Train it.
Test it.
Rinse and repeat, until
you end up with a model
that you're happy with.
Now, training with
huge data sets
actually takes a lot of time.
So you need a lot of
computing resources.
But it actually still takes
a lot of real world time.
So when it came to building
AutoML, what we thought was,
hey, rather than do this process
serially one after the other,
wouldn't it be great if we
could do it in parallel?
We could just come up with
a whole set of ML models.
And our AutoML controller
could farm them off
to different machines
on Google Cloud.
And we can use the highest spec
machines that are available,
the fastest CPUs, the
fastest GPUs if we want,
because GPUs are a great
way to train ML models
and use them for inferencing.
But we go one step further.
Google Cloud also offers TPUs.
Now, TPUs stand for
Tensor Processing Units.
And this is custom silicon
that Google has built,
and we make available
exclusively on Google Cloud.
So where GPUs are orders of
magnitudes faster than CPUs,
TPUs are several times
faster than GPUs too.
Now, to give you an example,
yesterday at the I/O Developer
Keynote, we talked about an
example of a company called
Recursion Pharmaceuticals.
Their training time with
TPUs went from 24 hours down
to 15 minutes.
A whole day down to 15 minutes.
So you imagine that you're
trying to build an ML model.
And you're constantly
training and tweaking.
That cycle that
you have to do, you
want to condense it
as much as possible.
So AutoML says, ah, don't
worry about all this.
We'll just send them all off.
And you decide how
long it trains for.
So the training
side of the billing
works based on training time.
We give you an hour for free.
And so at the end
of that time, we
look at the model that
performs the best.
And we serve it.
Based on our data,
what we found is
that AutoML produces ML models
that are more complicated
than what humans produce.
But they also perform better.
So let's have a look at an
example of AutoML Vision,
if we can just switch
to the machine.
Thank you.
So here is the console
for AutoML Vision.
And what we have is a
labeled set of images.
So remember our cloud
example, the flight simulator?
What I've done is I've
uploaded a ton of images.
There's about 1,800
images in there.
And these images
have been labeled.
On the left hand
side there's a label.
So I said there's
10 types of clouds.
We're only doing five
labels for this example.
And you'll see that the cirrus,
cumulonimbus and cumulus
have about 500 images.
I didn't have as many for the
alto cumulus and alto stratus.
So there are only
about 200 and 135.
But when I go through the
training, what you can see
is that I said do
it for 12 hours.
And it came up with a model
that's about almost 90%
in its accuracy.
When I look at how it evaluated
against the test data, what
we found is that this
thing is called a confusion
matrix, which basically
says, how well
did this model do at identifying
against the test data
that we provide?
So if you look at the ones
where we provided 500 images,
you get about 90% accuracy.
The one where we had fewer
images, it's only in the 60s.
Anyways, we're going to now
go ahead and predict what
these two clouds look like.
Now, typically, this
is just our console.
So we're just doing
some sample data here.
You would have an API end point.
And I'll show you
that in a second.
But anyways, you'll see
here with 99% accuracy,
or confidence, it said that this
is a cumulus, which is correct.
And then you can see that
with 73.7% confidence,
it says that this
is a cumulonimbus.
And it's far more
confident about that one
than the next one down.
So our model's actually
done a really great job.
Now, in terms of
an API end point,
we actually provide
you some example code.
Whether you want to use like
the curl statement, or even
some sample Python code on how
you can call your API yourself.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
So now we've solved our
flight simulator problem.
Right?
We're going to use
clouds to detect whether.
And we're done.
Now, AutoML Vision meant that
we had to write zero code.
And we didn't even
need to worry about how
this thing is going to be
deployed on infrastructure
and served globally.
But you might be saying, ah,
that's just a Vision example.
Give me some other normal,
like regular examples.
I want to talk to you
about a new product, one
that we just launched
a few weeks ago.
It's called AutoML Tables.
And pardon the pun, but
it's a game changer.
With AutoML Tables, you
take your structured data.
Now, that data can
be a spreadsheet.
It can be from your database.
And you pump it
into AutoML Tables,
where it will train
an ML model for you,
and deploy it at scale.
So you may be saying, well,
what are some examples that I
could use for AutoML Tables?
Well, actually, your
imagination is the limit here.
You could look at
tailoring game difficulty
to match the types
of players that you
have in any given encounter.
So you in real time
change the difficulty
of maybe that boss that you're
players are fighting against.
You could look at ways
to convert players
into paying players
through in app conversions.
Look at your historical
data to train AutoML tables.
You could use it
to identify fraud.
This is a very common challenge
that game developers tell us.
That, hey, we constantly get
these fraudulent transactions.
And, of course,
you can also help
it identify cheating
in your games
based on, again,
historical data.
So AutoML Tables is huge.
And Cloud AutoML in
general is, again,
like our ML APIs is broken
into several categories.
We have the site type things,
Vision and Video Intelligence.
We have Natural
Language and Translate.
I do want to call out, Natural
Language and Translate,
in particular, is
great for games.
So I gave you an example
earlier of Translate.
And we said, good luck.
Have fun.
We said, good game.
Most gamers don't
talk like that.
They use shorthand.
Right?
And especially when you
look at your own games,
you're going to have a
set of custom inventory
items, characters.
If you build card
games, maybe card decks.
With AutoML, you can
train those models
to learn your custom
terminology and adapt to it.
And so then you can
provide translations,
and natural language
sentiment detection as well.
And then, of course, we
talked about AutoML Tables,
which is a really big deal.
So so far we've looked at
kind of off the shelf products
that we offer you.
Now, I want to talk
about where ML is really
useful for game development.
We offer a number of
products that really help you
with building these ML models.
But ML, as I said earlier,
is that initial process
of training where we
tweak some parameters.
We train a model.
We test it.
And then we go back
to the start and do it
again and again until we find
a model that we're happy with.
The second half of it
is just as important.
Once you have a model
that you're happy with,
how do you deploy it at scale?
Do you deploy it locally
as part of your game
if it's a mobile game?
Do you send it down to
the console or desktop?
Or do you run your
AI in your cloud
where you need to be able to
have your AI simulated there?
How do you get the
reach across the world,
depending on where
your players are?
Well, for that we have what we
call the Google AI platform.
And the Google AI platform
offers training and prediction
services.
We have powerful and
flexible tools for ML
and data science, and
really a scalable and robust
infrastructure that Google
runs its own services on.
The other thing
we've done is we've
made available a virtual machine
image that's specifically
useful for deep learning.
And you can run it on our
product called Compute Engine,
which is where we host VMs.
But let me give you a
hypothetical example of a game.
This game itself
is actually real.
This is a mini game
called "Snowball Storm."
And it's part of
Google Santa Tracker.
If you've never heard
of Santa Tracker,
please check it out at
SantaTracker.google.com.
But in this game we built
a little bit of an homage
to the battle royale genre.
So at the start of it,
you're a little elf.
You parachute down onto
an island made of ice.
And you have to try and throw
snowballs at other players
to eliminate them.
The ice melts around
the edges over time.
And so we're constricting
players into a location.
Currently, the AIs and
the bots in this game
are not built on any ML model.
They're just very simple.
If we were to build something
like this for our own game,
we could build a
pipeline akin to this.
So I'll walk you through this.
On the left hand side what
we'll have is some players
playing against one another,
some player versus player
matches.
What we'd want to do is
record and log as much
of that information is we can.
Because the way
we're going to train
this bot is using a technique
called supervised learning.
So earlier I said DeepMind used
reinforcement learning, where
the AI kind of taught itself.
With supervised learning, we're
going to capture all this data,
and train our bot based on how
other players play the game.
So it's going to learn
off other information.
So what we'll do is
capture all of that.
We'll log that.
And we're going to
store it in a database
that we call Google BigQuery.
And with BigQuery, it's a
petabyte scaled NoSQL database.
So it's incredibly performant.
And when I say
petabyte scaled, it
can scan through petabytes
of data within seconds.
So we're going to
store all of our logs,
player logs into BigQuery.
We're going to
export that and make
it available on Cloud storage,
which is really just a place
to store your files.
You could think about
it as a private storage.
Kind of like Google Drive,
but not with a user interface
or anything like that.
It's literally for storage
of your private files
for your enterprise.
So you export from BigQuery,
store into Cloud Storage.
And then we're going to build
a model using TensorFlow
in our training phase.
And we're going to use
Compute Engine here,
which is what I said
earlier about where
we run virtual machine images.
We'll use that
deep learning image
that I talked about earlier to
train an AI model that learns
of our historical player data.
And then, once we have that
model, we'll export that model,
and store it in cloud storage.
Now, I've, of course, glossed
over the really hard part
of this, which is the training.
But this is where you do
require some ML expertise.
So when you or your
organization are
ready to kind of step
up and attempt this,
just know that it's more
than just running TensorFlow.
You need to have
an entire pipeline
of ingesting this data.
You need to be able
to do it at scale.
And ideally, with
the training phase,
you want to do it
as fast as possible,
so you can get really
quick cycles of iteration.
The next side of
it is inference.
So we have our AI model.
And what we want to be able
to do is make predictions.
Now, our AI might be
running server side.
And in this case, it would.
So it's easy for us
in the Cloud ML engine
to just be making
inference API calls,
to say, hey, what should my
next move be for this bot
and that bot?
And then when it comes
to running on our client,
all we're doing is
asking for predictions.
So you might say,
well, how can I
use machine learning
for game development?
What are some use cases for it?
The most obvious one is
actually for QA and testing.
So today when we have to make
changes to level design or game
balance, we have to spend
lots and lots of time
testing it to make sure we
haven't broken that balance,
we haven't introduced new bugs.
And today we rely
on people to do it.
If you're able to
build an ML bot that's
able to play the
game for you, you
can do testing across
the board in parallel.
You could farm it out to
thousands of machines.
You don't even need to
have the game playing back
in real time speed.
You could simulate it
as fast as possible.
So again, in terms of your
process for QA and testing,
you can get rapid
turnaround cycles for it.
Imagine a future
where we have smarter
non player characters,
where our players are
able to have realistic
dialogue with them,
and make realistic choices.
Those NPCs could even be
used to guide players.
So we see this a lot with
some of our partners,
where they have this
really complex, let's say,
card game, where
people have to build
a really well-balanced deck.
But it's really hard
for a new player
to know what kind
of choices to make.
Perhaps it's a
battle royale game
where you're trying to build
a squad that's well balanced.
For someone that's new to the
game or is a casual player,
they're not able to make
those right choices.
ML can help us build great
NPCs or recommendation
engines to help our players
through that process,
and help them make the right
choices to stay competitive.
Now, if we have bots that can
help us with QA and testing,
those bots can also be
used against real players.
So in a squad based game,
isn't it frustrating
when one of our players
drops, and now we're
left with an AI that's either
really bad at the game,
or exceptionally good?
I guess it's not so bad if
they're exceptionally good
and they're on your team.
But when they're exceptionally
good on somebody else's team,
it doesn't work out very well.
If we're able to build a good
comprehensive set of bots,
you can provide bots that are
tailored to the skill level,
or complements that
team particularly well
in those events.
So we've covered a
few scenarios today
of where machine
learning, I think,
is really going to
revolutionize with what
happens with game development.
So if you're looking
to just get started
with applying ML in your games,
and you don't have any ML
expertise, the APIs
are a great way
to get started, and capture
some of those quality of life
improvements for your games.
Because your
players will notice.
And integration with those
APIs is really, really simple.
It's literally an API call.
AutoML is able to help
you build custom models
for your scenarios
with your data,
again, with zero ML
expertise needed.
And then when you're
ready to take the step up
to building your own AI that's
able to solve problems, like do
automated QA testing,
or have smarter NPCs,
then step up to something like
the AI platform, which will not
only just help you train
your models at speed,
but it'll help you serve them
and deploy them out at scale.
So I want to say thank
you for joining me today.
Your time is really
valuable to us.
We have a couple of links here.
The first one is our
full set of AI products
at cloud.google.com/products/ai.
These are not game specific,
but have uses within games.
And then we have a set of gaming
solutions at cloud.google.com
/solutions/gaming as well.
Please reach out
to me on Twitter
if you want to get in touch.
And have a great I/O.
Thank you, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]